ach so kelly wir spielen jetzt also mit
schmutzigen mitteln deine mutter in
diesem kampf mit reinzuziehen
schämst du dich nichts tut mir leid
tennis mama liebe grüße an dich aber du
bist jetzt teil des krieges und ich
musste ich auch dementsprechend
behandeln als wir uns mal im echten
leben treffen sollten werde ich dir
natürlich komplimente machen aber heute
bist du mein feind es tut mir leid und
kelly eine dreistöckige torte ja du
gibst nicht auf und das bewundere ich
das bewundere ich sehr deswegen habe ich
mich vorbereitet
ich werde nicht noch mal den fehler
machen und unvorbereitet in einen krieg
ziehen ich habe mit meinem ipad schon
vor gemalt und ich möchte an dieser
stelle euch gleich durchführen durch
meinen plan
damit ihr wisst was passiert kelly hat
oben den tropen gemacht in der mittleren
gab es ein mittelding und unten gab es
den hellen boden drei verschiedene böden
an dieser stelle schon mal danke dafür
kelly tolle idee drei verschiedene böden
zu machen
ich würde aber sagen dass wir den
schurken ganz nach unten machen denn er
ist dunkel und ein dunkler boden sieht
glaube ich unten besser aus weil dunkel
wirkt schwerer und hell wird leichter
deswegen machen wir unten den showroom
in der mittleren schicht kommt eine
haselnuss irgendwas rein und um kommt
der helle boden ich finde das wirkt
harmonischer ich finde das wirkt kommen
wir zu der creme und zwar wird es
natürlich wieder ein naked cache das ist
ja irgendwie unser motto hier und mit
dem grip effekt warum warum aus den drei
perfekt gemacht effekt ist so schwer ich
habe keine ahnung wie ich das hinkriegen
soll dein drei perfekt sieht doch schon
recht gut aus ich will ihn aber perfekt
machen
zu den farben würde ich mich an meinen
orientieren allerdings nehme ich über
pastelltöne
denn das sieht sonst echt ganz schön
crazy aus kommen wir nun zur deko und
zwar marshmallows kurs marshmallows
vergessen dann kommt natürlich unsere
apple dazu und die erbin werde ich
dieses mal in weiße schokolade trinken
mit bunten perlen damit es zu diesen
ganzen bunten kern die cache dazu passt
und kennen die sollte nicht wählen also
ein paar süßigkeiten und das meine damen
und herren ist der kuchen den die
anstrebe verdammt was hast du uns da
angetan ist meine mutter mit reingezogen
ist so unsinnig wenn es auf kamehameha
so jetzt haben einen schlachtplan tag
nummer eins lasst uns kuchenbacken also
wir fangen mit unserem schokoladenkuchen
an weil der glaube ich am
kompliziertesten ist ihr seid da habe
ich mich natürlich wie immer an einem
fantastischen sally rezept bedient bei
der zubereitung zitiere ich jetzt mal an
dieser stelle die gute sally und zwar
sagt sie zuerst die butter in einem topf
zerlassen sie soll allerdings nicht heiß
werden sondern nur schmelzen schokolade
hinzufügen und ebenfalls schmelzen eier
zucker salz und vanille
in einer großen schüssel mit einem
schneebesen kurz verrühren die lauwarme
schokoladen butter mischung hineingeben
und sorgfältig verrühren mehl backpulver
und kakaopulver verrühren und ebenfalls
hinzugeben alle zutaten ganz kurz zu
einem glatten teig vermischen kommen wir
nun zu dem obersten kuchen und das wird
ein heller kuchen und da habe ich mich
wieder bei meiner besten freundin sally
ich zitiere eine springform oder besser
einen bug rahm vorbereiten und mit
backpapier auskleiden die eier mit dem
zucker salz und vanille extrakt circa
fünf minuten sehr schaumig rühren bis
die eier masse ganz hell ist öl und
wasser zufügen und kurz bei niedriger
stufe 1 hören die trockenen zutaten
vermischen und hinein sieben ganz kurz
bei niedriger stufe einrühren kuchen
nummer eins ist im backofen kummer 2
wartet auf den backofen und jetzt
brauche ich einen
die mittlere schicht einen nusko dafür
habe ich gemeine haselnüsse gekauft
nach mutter ich habe von meiner platten
kompliment von meiner nachbarin bekommt
einen kranz oder tür also für den
nusskuchen haben sozusagen von meiner
schwester bekommen wenn kelly hilfe von
ihrer mama nimmt die hilfe von meiner
schwester als eigentliches haselnuss
muffins aber machen sind eigentlich
kleine kugel
ich sehe gerade meine schwester hat auch
durch eine zubereitung notiert das heißt
ich zitiere dann diese stelle meine
schwester alina mehl backpulver und
haselnüsse in eine schüssel vermischen
in einer zweiten schüssel zugang vanille
zucker eier und milch früheren milde
wisch dazugeben und rühren chakalaka
roten retter rette die torte soll der
darf jetzt abkühlen so der helle tag
kommt jetzt schon mal hier rein
ok hier kommen wir
[Musik]
also sind kommentiert oben geht
irgendwann später und meine drei
schichten sind fertig einmal der helle
boden ganz oben pasel nusskuchen und der
regel schokokuchen die werden dann so
übereinander gestapelt und einnahmen
torte aber ihr dachtet doch nicht
wirklich dass ich das jetzt hier alleine
machen so kelly sich hilfe geholt hat
leute ich habe gerade schon meine sachen
zusammengepackt und ich werde mich auf
den weg nach buxtehude machen um mit
meiner schwester diese torte zu
vollenden
sie hat schon den anruf von mir erhalten
und bereitet in diesem augenblick die
füllungen vor raffaello kaffee und
vanillepudding kelly du hast dich mit
der falschen angelegt schweiz
ich bin jetzt bei meiner schwester es
sehr späte danach wollen wir uns mal
wieder verquatscht haben und ich hab die
kuchen mitgebracht und die werden willst
befüllen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt unser schönes creme wie
gut die bounty oder sich einfach voll
genommen
so jetzt wird die torte befüllt
[Musik]
das sieht so gut aus das ist so eine
gute idee mit dem rahmen aber unser
gucken wir dieses mal ein richtiger
geburtstagskuchen
dann hat man auch eine emotionale
support perfekt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
satzes platte ist darf sich also jetzt
kommt der bus kaufen also ich glaube sie
können
bis hierhin wegschneiden alles klar
machen wir im schokoladen mit sahne und
wir bestreichen
ja dann zeige ich euch jetzt nicht wie
ich wie wir schon wieder sahne steif
schlagen wir zeigen euch gleich wenn wir
die schichten machen
also wir damit von bakkal an sky markt
karamell
so dann wenn die tonne jetzt gefühlt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so lecker aus jetzt drücken also wir
haben in schärfe vanille konfitüre und
schmieren wir haben den boden das lecker
und dann kommt noch bevor ihn sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hast du ja wie fühlt sich das an
so schön so dann legen wir uns noch der
band schon da blumen herum
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also kann es mir noch die uhrzeit
verraten
328 nacht tag 2 es damit besiegelt
schlaf gut träumen was schönes
dritter tag nummer 2 33 wir haben unsere
kuchen böden jetzt stellen wir zusammen
ich habe tatsächlich die gleichen jobs
gefunden die kelly auch herz benutzt hat
aber in pastelligen tönen
also was kelly nicht gemacht hat und was
wir machen werden den kuchen
stabilisieren oh mein gott ich mache das
hier in die auf der verpackung nicht zu
knapp weil um ist hier dass er schlecht
und dabei den rändern
[Musik]
was du denkst laufen ja eigentlich da
wird jetzt gut runter laufen sie denn so
schön raus was wir machen können ist mit
dem füller martin pusten
ein erster schritt
das sieht gut aus du bist lange her
verlaufen
eigentlich so alina macht gerade die
eher bern geschwenkt
dann kommen die schönen strauß wunderbar
würde ich bereite schon mal die macarons
vor
das wird so schön aussehen meine fresse
und dann ja noch nie bekommen
du hast nur und dann aber auch raphael
[Musik]
450 gästen ja der saatgut aus dem
automaten von flachen 20 minuten später
so macht das sind spiele die amateure
übergab mich fertig gemacht
[Musik]
während meine nichte gerade ihre
geschenke auspacken ein wie die torte an
und können wir noch mal betonen
also ich weiss nicht kelly vielleicht ja
sagst du einfach mal was dazu zu diesem
meisterwerk denke ich mal so das zu
toppen
das versuch mal ja
[Musik]
guck mal
top wie jena mit
also dass unsere erste schicht meinen
hier zählt nur der geschmack
zum glück ist die oberste schicht
gewesen die der geschmack ist wir dürfen
diese ganzen tolle aufhörten zweite
schicht tief in den voll harmonisch vor
den wirklich richtig cool schicht nummer
3 der fall einfach ein perfekter gegner
des optisch alt er ist perfektion der
ist perfektion der wohnungsverein creme
die creme ist so leicht wirkt sie dazu
ich würde sagen ab tisch kriegen wir nur
zehn von zehn geschmacklich auf ich
mache mich auch langlebigkeit
naja gut sollte das war's mit dem
videospiel noch abschließende worte
sagen es war schön mit dir zu packen und
dann links mutter dumont
folgt man der schwestern irgendwo weil
sie nicht einfach
[Musik]